and now we have a special treat hold on
to your yarmulkes okay from east to west
you know they're the best getting you in
the zone for your milestone is that cute
please welcome go belt afresh and dr.
dreidel
[Music]
[Applause]
blue
all right when you see black people at a
Bar Mitzvah it's very exciting it's like
a scary ride and the kids just love it
right now we are the number one boss
slash Bob Mitzvah party motivators in
all of Nassau County I mean you got the
bat missiles always to men you know all
of them coming through like a ville de
hiya with the recycled dress and I mean
though let's put these guys with their
fakakta shtick it's it's a real Shaun
down what is supposed to be simcha yeah
yeah you're supposed to be a simcha just
really can't put a price on the look on
your child's face when they see a black
person for the first time
[Music]
oh it's just magical really is he
getting back up or what we're not
technically chosen but chosen by the
chosen us and which is kind of better
than being just the chosen that's right
it's less responsibility Jews are like
black people but we were black people
before there were black people well I
guess that's not true they were just in
a different part of the world they're
all black people coming to get me help
[Music]
[Applause]
but spiritually intoxicating find it
culturally fascinating and we find it
monetarily exhilarated I mean the fact
that we're willing to put forth the
extra time is what sets us apart I mean
how often is a thirteen-year-old gonna
hear their own name
we learned that name we rehearse it
[Applause]
Judaism can be a very somber religion
that's right you know something we
learned along the way is that the word
ghetto means something very different to
these people to tell you the truth I was
a little nervous about the whole thing
and no not because they were black but
because you never really know what those
kind of people are gonna do if we can
have some fun some life some color to a
Jewish person's life when they're still
young they might not grow up and run
away from black people when they see him
maybe they won't or fire people so
willy-nilly when they're older we
provide a service that he's feeding a
motive a potty's so that's what we do
that's what we do with motivate parties
[Music]